- So the question is,
can a new president revoke the
pardons of an old president?
I'm just, you know, curious
for no reason whatsoever.
And the answer is it depends.
Because it always depends.
But we have some historical precedent.
President Ulysses S. Grant
actually revoked several pardons
from former President Andrew Jackson.
And the revocation actually went through
with respect to two men
because they were in prison at the time
and the warden hadn't actually given them
the physical document.
It was almost literally on his desk.
So you can revoke a pardon
that hasn't been delivered.
But with respect to another man
that Grant tried to revoke the pardon of,
he had already taken
possession of that pardon
and the court said that you can't revoke
that particular pardon.
So if that precedent still holds,
and that's always a question,
then pardons that haven't
actually been given
to the pardonees can be revoked,
but if they have been
delivered they can't.
So I guess the lesson is work fast.
Stay tuned for more
presidential legal news,
and as always, I'll see you in court.